I am a girl I am a girl I am a girl I am
a girl I am a girl I am a girl I am a
girl
from Claire I'm from Huntington Beach
and I'm 24. I'm hania I'm 26 and I'm
from Inglewood I'm saying um I'm 23 and
I'm from Long Beach California I'm Mia
I'm 19 and I'm from Pasadena California
I'm Celeste I'm 19 and I'm from Culver
City California I'm Casey I'm 18 and I'm
from Los Angeles California my name is
Natalie but you can call me Nat I am
from Washington I recently moved here
for work but yeah for the most part my
technique coming in was like a more
masculine take on it because if I was
too girly then it would be too obvious
what's everyone wearing I'm in some
sambas black jeans and like a light
greenish tops okay I'm wearing Levi's
um a like bodysuit and then dunks and a
little cardigan too I'm wearing like a
purple skirt like a white off the
shoulder top kind of let's go like
what's everyone's shoe size oh I'm a
size 10 10 yeah 10 in women's how tall
are you 5 10. oh yeah so that makes
sense I'm a short girly I'm 411 without
these heels
uh on a good day on 5'4 though I am
wearing size 7.5 I think it's pretty
average for girls I guess I'm I'm like
five three I'm a size five I'm six foot
and I have a shoe size of nine so I like
how we all just started sharing our eyes
can I ask you guys something yeah what's
like your biggest insecurity oh good
question hard-hitting I was suspicious
of hania at first just because she
seemed to be asking a lot of the
questions and having a lot a large role
in the discussion I got a big old
forehead
I'm coming for everyone with a regular
forehead because y'all sound like y'all
got regular foreheads like I'm getting
regular forehead energy here
laughing was a big thing for me they
were laughing a ton and I was trying to
I was trying to like
it just didn't work out so yeah I was
trying my best I think the biggest thing
for me is acne I have it on my face and
my back and it's pretty bad especially
when I want to go to the beach and so
it can be pretty annoying
I have a I have another question what's
your like usual go-to style for me not I
think I would say like an urban like
comfy style I'm not super fancy as a
person so
um yeah I would say Urban comfy whatever
is currently in style I try to stick to
that yeah but that's how I feel too I
mean I try to keep mine just like
Timeless wearing Timeless like pieces
that yeah keeping very practical I'm
wearing a tank top right now so it works
out what did you guys want to be when
like you were a little girl I really
wanted to be a veterinarian Sam I really
loved animals I still love animals I was
a horse girl I can relate to that um
actually I have horses back in
Washington so yeah oh my gosh one of
them's name is Scooby-Doo
he's adorable I assembled like a speech
for certain questions but there were
certain questions that were just
completely off what they were like off
the page like the horses thing I just
jumped in as soon as I could I'm like
yeah I have horses I don't have horses
for me I've always wanted to be like a
singer songwriter so that's what I'm
trying to do okay can you sing so I'm
assuming you can sing yeah I do I write
my own songs and I like release them
okay so we're going to be like your
first fan yeah yeah for sure that'd be
awesome Casey's voice is kind of high so
it did make me a little suspect I'm like
she kind of sounds like a princess from
a Disney movie and that doesn't just
happen I wanted to be an obstetrician
gynecologist oh and then I got to UCLA
and took chemistry and I was like oh we
gonna switch that around
yeah I was like biochem I was like oh
absolutely not I'm a stand-up comedian
now though I don't know
he's lying because they explained too
much that's what it was like okay she
she planned this script out pretty well
so so did you guys go to school like
college or anything yeah
I graduated from like a small little
school in Boston
um it's called LaSalle but it's not
really well known but yeah so I was over
there for four years and then this is
like my first full year being back
yeah
hey do you think I'm gonna win this
episode be sure
do you think I'm gonna win this episode
be sure to like And subscribe and let's
get back to the video
it was actually a three-way time
we don't trust each other
let's move on to round two with all of
you I have the first question okay what
was you guys's first period like I was
just gonna say okay perfect yeah we got
to get down to the nitty-gritty yeah for
me I was you it wasn't because I read
like the American Girl doll books and
everything yes yeah for me it was over
the summer before ninth grade and I was
getting ready to go to track practice
and then just happened I was like oh
well I guess I'm a woman now yeah I was
like I was kind of behind everybody else
so I knew it was going to come soon so I
was kind of ready for it I was in the
sixth grade bathroom and I was freaking
out and my friends were outside so when
I got home I told my mom and she just
like shoved me a pad and said hey try
that like put this on and then here so
you never I don't know it's like maybe
it's an Asian thing she just never
talked to me about it I think I was in
seventh grade I'm pretty sure I was at
home and I like went to the bathroom and
I saw that there was blood and I didn't
know what to do I didn't want to call my
mom for some reason so I called my
cousin I was like I don't know what's
going on like help me I've never had to
talk or anything I did which was like
the funny part like I don't know I and
then I eventually told my mom like after
her but yeah yeah my cousin was the
first one that knew so I was in seventh
grade math class and it was super
awkward I was rescusing at my desk I
felt a really weird and like sensation
below my stomach and I was really
confused because they were talking about
interesting stuff in health class before
that point but eventually I just ran to
the bathroom because I just didn't feel
good okay there's no way one of you
isn't that girl
I had no idea about anything involving
periods or anything like that so I just
went with it name something really
specific that only a girl would get like
specific don't just say pad
um I have really insane cramps so I have
Midol on me at all times okay that's
specific at all times I have to have it
how do you know you're like how do you
know when your period's coming I have
really really bad lower back pains and
I'm like in pain for like two days
before and I always get the same pimple
around my lip area oh insane period is
anyone irregular well I started birth
control and like it's really screwed me
up like I started the next plan on so
that's something another girl like
specific specific has anybody had any
like scary experiences that they
associate with being a woman oh yeah and
it's really disgusting kind of what
happens when you're just existing as a
woman one time at a college party a guy
talked to me for like two seconds and
then the next day I found out that he
was telling everyone that I slept with
them
um you say yes as a woman you're a [__]
you say no as a woman you're a prude if
you're somewhere in between people still
find a way to hate you yeah preach to
them yeah I would say like the hyper
vigilance required to like go places by
yourself yeah and there's little things
we do that I don't know if everyone
knows we do like oh let me just pretend
that I'm playing music in my ears like
no music playing let me just go on the
weather
comes normal but it really shouldn't
have to be a normal to always have to
feel like you have to protect yourself
like a force field do you guys know
anyone or like if you want to share like
that has experienced sexual assault
um I'll volunteer myself I've came so
far to be able to volunteer myself
publicly and I'm proud of myself I've
experienced sexual assault and I think
it does have a very like it Hawks your
your growth as far as what you feel you
should be mentally as a woman but
there's a lot of emotional and spiritual
things that you have to do in order to
fully evolve to to even volunteer
yourself as Tribune to say that um
acknowledge that the word Survivor also
is kind of like iffy for me because I
feel like oh like oh I survived that
like you know like it's almost like I'm
pitting myself I don't know I don't even
know what to call it like Survivor and
like I don't even know like it's just
weird yeah it's any any word that feels
comfortable to you
I made it past one round that's what I
came in here to do today I'm actually
happy that I was the first one voted out
so yeah okay to go a little bit deeper
because I need to figure out who the
ball is how do you guys feel about
abortion oh
um yeah deep for me I'm pro-choice I
believe everyone has the decision to do
whatever they want with their body and
within pro-choice also exists pro-life
if you believe that you are pro-life for
yourself I feel like I would probably be
pro-life for myself just because I I
don't know it's scary to go through just
a medical procedure if you don't want to
do it you don't want to do it if you do
want to get an abortion like you do like
it's fine like that's the whole point of
pro-choice I feel like and the
government shouldn't be the ones
deciding so exactly who's like a like a
good like role model that you have like
a woman role model that's really good
um I don't want to be cliche but I'm
gonna have to say my mother get it yeah
were y'all thinking that too yeah yeah
like she blows my mind it's it's it
truly flabbergasts me the things that
moms do
and they make it seem like it's Slight
Work my go-to person is my dad like he
is everything to me and he has taught me
what it is to be an upstanding person
society and to respect everyone so I
just yeah
if you want to keep playing because you
think the mole is in the Box raise your
hand one two three
okay I'm suspicious of somebody okay I
have a reason
um hania what's up so you were quiet
during the abortion topic and I just
like and like you've been kind of really
talkative recently so like that kind of
like red flagged me a little bit oh let
me fix that up for you so
um I also did I mentioned that I am a
survivor of assault so abortion usually
gets me really choked up I feel like
it's my body and it's my choice so the
whole conversation when I when I debate
about it it does give me a little
trigger so I usually refrain from
heavily like impactful like my opinion
what I have to say about it but I'm mad
at you
wait Casey were you the
um songwriter yes okay can I ask you
something Casey yes what is the the
metal u-shaped thing in your bra do you
know what that's called
I don't know what that's called I do not
the underwire yeah the underwire I
thought you meant something else because
that's like on both cups what's
something that like you wish you didn't
experience as a woman or like I'm gonna
go Boop sweat oh oh my gosh so real so
real mustache sweat
[Music]
one Hindi asked the question about
underwire on the bra I didn't know the
answers I was like okay they're gonna
vote me out I knew it
playing because you think the mall is
still in the box you will raise your
hand one two three
okay you know playing along and finding
the mole is fun and all but want to know
what's even more fun finding pleasure
within yourself
are you wondering what that means well
come a little closer and we'll tell you
and what's so great is that everyone can
experience it explore what this looks
like for you and all the wonders of
self-love with Lilo so what are you
waiting for get started on your journey
Now by using code girls30 for 30 off
your first Lilo purchase because nothing
thing says self-love like treating
yourself as your own lover thank you to
Lilo for sponsoring this portion of the
video now let's get back to the video
[Music]
surprise for themselves if the Box turns
green you four have correctly voted
alcohol and we'll share the cash prize
[Applause]
[Music]
honestly it's a weird experience but no
it starts appear it's cool it goes ten
nine eight seven six five four three two
one
oh my God Matt looks like he was in like
High School Musical or something like
Camp Rock so when I opened my eyes and
saw Zac Efron I was like okay you got me
like I really feel like I've been
bamboozled I do a YouTube channel
what oh some gaming stuff and so yeah
that's what I do that's really whoa
whoa
I felt like I was already out of my
element so I had to like go in there and
try to be somebody that I'm not I was
scared coming into this because I didn't
want to fall into stereotypes because I
know I don't want people to stereotype
me I don't want like no one wants that
no one wants to be assumed I was
thinking about just busting out
different voices like oh my god
oh you got accents too I know I got you
because like I'll do an Australian but I
still do like a it's quite weird you
should be a voice actor I was thinking
about it yeah